[Music]
so
[Applause]
hi everyone this is the first video in a
three-part series covering my road trip
from the uk to russia back in 2018.
most of the time was spent driving
across scandinavia taking ferries
visiting different places on route
before finally arriving in saint
petersburg
i spent a week there trading in aikido
and this is all recorded in part two
with this series
if you've got any questions about my
trip feel free to ask in the comments
below
also if you enjoyed the video please
remember to give it a like share and
subscribe if you haven't done so already
anyway with that being said i'll leave
you to it and i hope you enjoyed the
[Music]
trip
i did about 800 miles yesterday i stayed
just outside of hamburg
when this lay-by where
some people have been staying in the
cars and camper vans and what have you
today i'm going to crack on to denmark
and this evening i've got a ferry so um
let's get going
so this road going between germany and
denmark
and uh i was here a couple of years ago
and
it had road works on it then and it
still does
and it's still got delays and
i think it's the only road that i hate
more than the m1
in england so the traffic's finally
cleared
something i'm saying we're just under
four hours away and although it did say
that two hours ago so
we'll see what happens so just hit a
thousand miles
um i'm in denmark now just a couple of
about an hour away from
the ferry port so i thought i'd
celebrate with the mcdonald's
[Applause]
finished my maccades now i just thought
i'd take the seating crew to the
ports let's see what there is
[Applause]
so that's the part over there that i'm
going to uh getting the furry from
we're heading over there in about about
an hour
okay i'm just at the ferry park in greno
now um
seems like there's some sort of festival
going on uh
we've only got a about an hour or so now
um
so i've really got time to go there but
maybe next time so i wanted to show you
on the map
um the route that i'm doing but to be
honest the map that i've got is a bit
crap you can't really see
um you can't really see anything
so far i've gone all the way down here
from um
bradford down to dover through france
um through the netherlands sorry belgium
first then the netherlands
um germany and then
up to uh denmark where we are now and
i'm just about to cross from here from
uh uh grinner or at least i think that's
how you pronounce it i'm not sure
so from grena i'm crossing over to
varberg which is just off the map and
the other map doesn't
show it on here so that's good um
so that's the route that i'm doing i'm
not sure if you can see on my phone
anyhow i should be in
sweden in the morning sometime
day three uh just coming out the ferry
park now
so the roads are absolutely dead
probably because it's 5 am in the
morning and no one's up
i thought there's a car there
it's all good
[Applause]
okay see me all right there
there's a few cars going past so i don't
know
turns out i didn't need a bit more of a
sleep well rested now
going to make a cup of tea test this out
for the first time and
carry on with the journey
i'll try that see how it goes
okay got my teeth sided everything
charging
it's all good
[Music]
me
so i think i'm going to stay here for
the night um seems like a pretty good
spot
apart from there's a pair of sandals on
the floor i don't know who they belong
to
um yeah so i've um
what we've done today um i had a bit of
a drive around went to a few lakes
finished with a swim in the lake um
took some drone shots although crash
landed by joan
um got it a bit wet
hopefully that will be all right i'll
test it out in the morning
and see how that goes
i've also done a bit of foraging a bit
earlier on today i've got a selection of
berries here
so uh that's going to be my start for
dinner
and um and then i'll finish it off with
uh
some noodles some tasty noodles so um
yeah i just need to find a fork for them
where did i put it
yesterday i got my drone a bit wet in
the water um
didn't fully submerge but just partly i
think just this front bit here
uh went underwater so um
what happened is it hit the side and
then just kind of
slid kind of landed like this and then
just slid into the water
anyway um
so i'm going to test it out this morning
make sure it's working all right and
then move on to the next place
[Music]
okay seems all good let's go
so just a bit of a hold up on the way to
stockholm
um it looks like there's been some sort
of accident someone's hit the
central reservation um from the other
side of the road and it seems like
there's a load of debris and glass and
what have you
on this side which they're just cleaning
up at the moment so
i don't know how long we're gonna be but
we'll see
okay we seem to be moving now
so before arriving in stockholm i plan
to meet up with ahima club
and go train with them unfortunately
this the material i was used to some
miscommunications so instead i just
spent the time exploring the city
it was my first time in stockholm and i
really liked the seat despite it being
really expensive
the old town was particularly nice and i
spent quite a bit of time wandering
around there
[Music]
i wasn't as keen on the modern part
though as it seemed to be under
construction with cranes everywhere
and i mean literally everywhere
[Music]
so after walking around all day i headed
back to the old town as i wanted to find
a cliched viking tavern to get some food
the restaurant that i found in the end
turned out to be exactly what i expected
the atmosphere was great and the food
was expensive but it was worth the
experience
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
right next stop finland another night in
the car
ferry port rather than
i thought i'd get here early um there's
myself and a few other cars and the few
of the trucks
and then yeah i'm just gonna have a bit
of sleep here until
it's time to get the ferry at about ten
past seven and then it's another 11
hours to
um to turku and then
drive from turku to helsinki
so see you in a bit
so just gone through check-in um and now
i'm just waiting to mount the board with
princess uh she's quite a big ship
um on the way to circo
so the room's pretty good um
it's actually you can fit four people in
here um
i've got it all to myself get the toilet
shower
above for about 60 quid can't complain
let's have a look at the view outside
all right just got shot and changed
let's go for a walk
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
time to get going
dolls have opened feel refreshed after
that trip and just
ready and waiting to set off to helsinki
[Music]
so this is my first time in finland um
apart from the time that i had a
stopover flight but
so technically i wasn't fiddling before
but uh it's my first time that i've
actually
driven in finland first time that i've
actually been on
well outside of the airport so anyway um
yeah first time in finland it's actually
the furthest that i've driven
east of the uk so you record for me
i don't know if you can hear the rain
outside but it just literally just got a
torrential
really bad
[Music]
i think we're in the center of helsinki
now somewhere um
at least near the center uh i'm gonna go
and get some food
um i'll try and find some food if
anyways open
and also i need to find somewhere to
sleep
it's early morning now um just up for
sunrise
i thought i'd get some pictures of the
lake
so i just checked out the um just
checked out the hotel
i've got four hours to kill
do i go to the national park or national
[Applause]
[Music]
museum
my
[Music]
love you
so i'm in a bit of a rush and i've only
got
about an hour before i need to be at the
ferry point so uh
need to move on
so i finally made it
taking a bit of time with my passport
so it's supposed to be setting up at six
it's now just after five and
on the third car through so
taking this along with each car
might be setting off a bit late
in england
it should be on the v5 the other you
know in the plastic
the plastic document yeah it's got my
registration i'm thinking
i think there was another paper the mot
which is behind it it should drop down
uh no no it's it was a loose paper um
it's dropped down on there
no no no not inside it was it should be
on the table yeah that's it
that's the mlt
yeah no problem
just doing the papers
right here inside
[Applause]
get full back
so although it seemed like i was the
third person
in a car at least uh to turn up
and the customs guy seems adamant that
we're still gonna set off on time so
um even though there's a bit of delay uh
there was one of the car after me that
has got through i think the others are
still
going through the um passport control
um i don't really know what the hold up
was but
anyhow we're um
we're being led by this van in front um
there's a coach in front of me and then
there's a van uh
to the next
i suppose it's the bit where we get
unfair
rooms not quite as snazzy as the last
ship but it's all right you'll do
um it's all good um
finally got on board i don't know what
the delay was yeah there just wasn't
that many
cars underneath and this was just
probably less than half an hour before
we set off
um because we set off pretty much on
time
and um but yeah when i came in i found
that there's a lot of
passengers um of course foot passengers
so what i'm guessing is that just not
that many people
drive their cars to russia which um
worries me slightly and i just think why
are
less people driving because the two i
think the two cars behind me were
russians
uh the two in front were
a team that were traveling from germany
and they're on some light expedition
um and then there was me so
uh yeah and that was it as far as the
cars there's a coach
and then some trucks um but i didn't see
any other cars
so it just seems really weird unless
some came later on
um but the majority just seemed to be
foot passengers
right i think they're serving the second
helping so i'm going to go and eat now
and check out the rest of the ship
okay the right hand side repeat all the
non-russian passengers i have to process
to the customs hall one
on the right hand side the weather
forecast for tomorrow a couple of
morning showers temperature 25 degrees
above zero
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for your attention now we can finally
take the winter flattering relax
on behalf of the captain on our crew we
wish you a very question stay on board
today
smoking funky
okay so where
which is here so i think i'm gonna go
and check out the princess's garden
let's see what there is to eat there um
[Music]
some other places but i think that's a
buffet so it's all you can eat
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
to get
still got dessert together
[Music]
oh
all right i'm definitely done after this
fruit and see
[Applause]
that's me done um i'm gonna walk it off
and
[Applause]
see what there is i might go outside
get them refreshing
just chilling up at the top of the deck
so good
[Music]
i'm passport control now nearly an
hour's just gone by
and get my car all the way through
um quite thoroughly and
i've had to fill in some forms and what
have you
um i'm just waiting now
let's go see that right finally made it
to some petersburg
um on the way to the hotel now it's in
the satnav
um finally we're in russia
[Music]
this might be the place i think
finally made it um i need to contact the
woman who owns the apartment though and
i don't know how so
i need to find a shop or something
to buy a sim card um so i'm gonna have
to go for a bit of a walk
okay let's go i'm in the apartment now
i'm pretty much settled in
um uh i'll show you around
kitchen
[Applause]
see my car outside there
okay so that's the apartment um it's
quite nice it's um
it's fairly big and for the price
considering we're in some pizzas
i think it's pretty good uh it's a
decent bed so
it's the first proper rest that i'm
gonna get in just over a week
um so i think it's gonna be pretty good
um yeah it's got plenty of space
the um everything's nice and clean
um looks like a pretty good spot cars
right outside
um couldn't really ask for much more
else um
the dojo where we're going to be
training
is just literally just down the road
rubles are still a bit like monopoly
money to me so i still need to get my
head around the currency
um but it's all good um
so yeah i'll grab a quick shower and
then i'm gonna head out
so yeah this is the area that i'm
staying in and
i'm just walking to the dojo now it's
not too far away
so i've just arrived here it looks like
this is the building
let's go inside
so
[Music]
english
[Applause]
[Music]
you